>> Hi, I'm a researcher from the
Bing Question and Answer
Experience Team, and I'm just
introduced DeepFind what demo,
Yeah.
Okay.
If you search -- if you search
how long do groundhogs live
here, you can see an enhancement
search result returns the wiki
page.
And from the wiki page
enhancement result you can
always get the answer for the
query directly.
And if not, and if you want to
scroll more, then open their --
that's overlaid, show up in the
search page.
You can use the -- maybe there
is more like a control F
searches query on the wiki page,
and some enhancements such as
you can use conversational
manners for the query here,
allows you to -- what do -- you
can use this to represent the
groundhog you just searched
before.
And another extension here is
that you could get the answer
for whatever you search in
highlight part and you can also
use some suggest questions on
the scroll more wiki page.
Actually, how long do they live,
what is the groundhog, and you
will get a result on the overlay
directly.
Okay.
That is what we have.